[Music]
goodbye kyle
look at this water we're gonna give them
something to talk about
[Applause]
who's coming up here with me
all right
it's a party now i'm losing my foil
theresa did you fight into the ball i
was sucking them up that ball yeah they
did
look
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
around these cameras hi girls hi nicole
the ramona coaster because she is all
over the place let's just get to know
each other do you want to be a friend to
anyone she was like i'm not signing this
paper if you cast my brother and my
sister that was a little irritated by me
you kind of kicked it off your mom is
not my friend you're my friend so
exactly
i don't give a you're not a girl's girl
why would you say that
you are so self-absorbed it's crazy
what you're not going to do is take you
to me
who do you think you are ramona
goes against the family this is why i
wrote my campaign
i thought my friends in beverly hills
would matter to me is that how boring
around these girls
teresa said she wasn't biting i said the
same thing but kyle you licked enough
balls last night let's have someone else
win
you